right as we come to you from the swamp
the sewer that is Washington DC joining
us now at the big reaction to breaking
news tonight counsel to the president
Kelly and Conway good to see how are you
I'm great John you like it we didn't
give you any heat they actually have
they have a time I give it to the guest
I don't need to give it seat welcome
back this is not small we've you've been
in the White House for the entire year
there's no evidence of this collusion
narrative of the media
I've watched you try and fight with
these idiots over on each whole Network
papers on your show they're so easily
baited collusion delusion no collusion
and here we are six months later and
still but here we are also it's a very
serious matter now of course what we
outraged dad let me know the fix was in
on Hillary's email so she could keep
running we know the people involved we
have the text messages and then we know
that her pain for dossier was used to
spy on a opposition candidate and an
incoming president this isn't funny
look I want to make something very clear
the president went to Quantico last
month he respects greatly the rank and
file of the FBI in 25,000 or so men and
women who work very hard and who are not
involved in this particular episode we
are just processing the memo at the
White House the president will look upon
it very deliberatively he takes it very
seriously but at this moment we should
just leave it to those who are going out
and investigating and making some new
facts notice some of your guests are
doing so that the American people could
at least have the transparent
accountable way to decide what they
would they see here the president
they're focusing on that man in the
White House giving a speech right behind
us in the Capitol there's a big story to
tell that again I have to go back to the
media that they have never told it
they've never talked about we have 2.2
million new jobs 2 million fewer people
on food stamps consumer confidence
through the roof two quarters of three
plus percent GDP growth and we still the
tax plan kicks in in February let's keep
going even before it quote kicks in Sean
you have as of this morning two hundred
and seventy four employers company
taking action directly related to the
tax no no there crumbs recorded thousand
I was poor in my life in my adult life
crumbs is a thousand or two thousand
dollars twelve that's according to Nancy
Pelosi it sounded much like that comment
the deplorable sand they're just so out
of touch if they're so out of the
mainstream so out of touch with America
tonight the Senate rejected the
Democrats rejected an ability to put
into law the pain cave Louisville over
you would ban abortions after the twenty
month when a fetus from Gill pain
they're so out of touch with America
calling that crumbs it's a real bread
lady it's not crumbs what's the real
bread thousands of our two thousand
dollar bonuses raises and wages but
obviously you see all these companies
repatriating their wealth now agreeing
to create new jobs here all the
factories coming back all the
manufacturing over two hundred thousand
manufacturing jobs created and Sean this
is very simple in 2010 when the
Democrats lost control of the House
Nancy Pelosi was no longer the speaker
and like they won't be again Barack
Obama went on to be successfully
reelected we he even admitted that they
had suffered a shocking but they were
all trying to defend their votes for
Obama care and that was becoming
increasingly unpopular Fischer the
Republicans are gonna brag about the
route for tax cuts and what it means to
the American people so far you over
three million Americans who have
directly benefited from that tax cut
because of what their employers have
done and the pressure is on other
employers now if you don't go ahead and
reinvest that money in your work force
in your workplace those workers will go
somewhere else we are becoming a nation
of jobs amazing chamber we have since
the history of what I'm taking
demographics on unemployment the lowest
unemployment level for black Americans
Hispanic Americans women 17-year low
teens it's down it's amazing and it's
incredible the reason you don't hear it
is because people are focusing on other
things but it almost doesn't matter
why folks know that their 401 k's are
fatter they know their confidence is up
and they're spending more money they
know that they invest the value of their
retirement savings or education savings
this president's tax bill expands the
529 savings plan through education that
allows you to save money for your
children up very little coverage it's
very little coverage we're gonna
continue to talk about it because that's
key and what are people going to ask me
how do we get women how to talk about
the education savings expansion this is
what people care about
but this president between the
regulations the taxation Isis is on the
run what he's done in one short year to
stimulate this economy but Luther and to
make us prouder is really remarkable
back to our top story Andrew McCabe is
gone this memo is going to be released
I'm told it will shock the conscience
then you have an investigation fixed on
top of our primary Hillary Clinton's
primary but an investigation obviously
fixed when crimes were committed no
wonder people are shouting locker up but
it gets worse than that then her phony
Russian dossier used as a foundation to
get a warrant to spy on Donald Trump in
his campaign and an incoming president
this to me is the biggest political
scandal in American history
Sean I you know what happens when we
talk about the 2016 elections and that
woman who lost miserably you should have
won whose name I'm not allowed to say on
TV anymore her they say you just can't
get over the election we're way past it
but this is not about an election that
Donald Trump won in our Constitution
it's about democracy in the Constitution
it's about people being able to know if
justice and democracy has been server D
when you go for all that evidence and
you go through all revelations you
scratch your head yet again you're
thinking this woman had every advantage
all the king's horses all the king's men
all the money all the personnel the
media and still blew it well you know
famously people were telling her gosh I
just was in Michigan in Wisconsin
there's Trump Pen signs ever there's no
Hilary science and you better get out
here but they didn't come Kellyanne I
know you working hard every day really
be a great State of the Union address
tomorrow everybody should watch it gravy
on them immediately thereafter